it's up to four so far so do you have
1/5 1/5 one number five say that again
did you just make up away okay so uh hmm
wait so you're saying disabilities
language okay so whereas why would she
be better at doing that so could we have
an interpret for the computer as well
exactly that's exactly translate human
translators can also be inaccurate okay
so you're talking about input for how to
get data into the system right okay now
what how do you how do you phrase it
isn't it about how you import data into
the system it is right now
I'm gonna put a warning on you because
that is very very close to this one I'll
just distinguish them okay in terms of
what kind of doll I think that's a
better way to say it the language issue
when you said you know people with
special needs and you know Braille or
kind of thing I think that's only just
barely acceptable but there's a warning
on that okay can you guys go any better
do you have anything else
welcome to pay that situation happens if
there's a connection this connection it
can probably go on the internet or go on
a why the best way to get out of the
cave and some people may say I'll just
stay put some people might like or just
I'm
I think we've got enough of that answer
I think the problem was about the
limitations is programming right that's
is that the key that I'm getting but you
can only do the things that it really
knows how to do whereas you can be say
how would you put up what's the opposite
what can you ban do